[Applause]
yo r.i.p larry king bro i was
you know this is how you know mark was
really going through this
did that see how i did this this is how
you know you know this is how you know
mark was so
jealous of my weekend alone yo
i texted him i was like bro i'm just
doing whatever i want to do
right now he goes he goes he just rifles
off mad things that he wishes he could
be doing he goes
yeah just like scrolling forever and
nobody says anything
i just want to watch tick tocks in peace
okay pretty face with a big bank
okay and i was like i was like nah but
that should kind of sound little
um [ __ ] larry king though right and i
was like bro why
and he goes oh no i'm just seeing all
these like interviews he seems kind of
like a douche and i go
i go i will say one thing his shoulders
annoy me
like his shoulders are just always up
like this and mark goes
yeah bro that's why you wear suspenders
to keep him down
his shoulders are literally the tallest
part of his body it's true he was just
like
didn't look like god been trying to drag
him up to heaven
or he's in the claw bro he's in the claw
game but but it came out right with
larry king so he died and obviously
everybody posted like how amazing he was
and that kind of [ __ ] and like
i'll be honest with you bro larry king
is one of those people where like
i'm trying to think what it's akin to um
you ever have any like unchecked
greatness because it's such an
institution
snl yeah but like now we recognize that
it's not funny right
but it's like there was there was a time
i guess where like larry king was just
that dude
and i've never watched a larry king
interview in my life but i've said out
of my mouth like oh yeah larry king
that's the goat
yeah but why i never watched him be the
goat
does that make sense and i think that
there were certain times that were there
were people there figures that were just
so prominent you assumed they had to be
great because they were in this position
barbara walters right got bodied by sean
connery
[Laughter]
[ __ ] nothing she could do
nothing she could do she was like yo you
hit women he's like yup
keep talking see what happens no no he
didn't say that
that's the vibe that's the energy get
rid of that speech impediment for you
knock some [ __ ] back into you so this
this dude pierce morgan right who's kind
of become like a
like a right-wing troll yeah in his his
career
um he basically said that like larry
king
trashed his show when pierce replaced
larry should we read the tweet
yeah let's read the tweet if we had the
exact tweet but he kind of came for
larry
but he came for larry and justified it
by what larry said about him
yeah but here's my thing if you've
watched larry king's interviews
he don't give a [ __ ] so i don't think
larry
would take it personally in his death if
people didn't give a [ __ ] and they said
how they really felt i just didn't like
that he made
somebody else's death about him yeah so
here's the here's the tweet i can read
it if he was like yo
it's chancellery you're kind of an
[ __ ] to everybody but you know it is
what it is i've got you don't need to do
that
but it ain't about you at least this is
all about him okay i'm with you on that
i do think that's selfish but i also do
think that's what human beings do is
like when anybody dies you post a
picture of you and that person
yeah you know as if like you need an
excuse to put on your timeline yeah yeah
but like so the tweet is larry king was
a hero of mine until we fell out after i
replaced him at cnn
and he said my show is like watching
your mother-in-law go over a cliff
and your new bentley he married eight
times so a mother-in-law expert that's
kind of funny
but he was a brilliant broadcaster in a
masterful tv
interviewer the whole thing is just let
me get attention he's just a child
acting out
yeah he wants some attention but he also
wanted to throw a shot yeah
but he did it in a clever way it's a
funny joke yeah but also like if you're
posting about someone's passing with you
in it like are you also just not trying
to get attention in the first place
you know what i mean like yeah maybe
yeah like let's say larry king dies he
has this picture with him he has like a
relationship with larry king
and he just goes r.i.p to one of the
best love this guy
like you're getting attention regardless
yeah i mean like
that's that's what i was saying like
that's what we do now he's an attention
play either way
exactly so he just like leaned into it i
don't hate this
i understand pierce is like a troll and
i get what he's trying to do
he's hateable for other [ __ ] too yes and
he wasn't always this way
which is kind of funny i think him
losing his cnn show is what made him it
flipped him yeah yeah he's like [ __ ] it
i got to get attention
already i might as well lean into the
hate yeah and these people
what's that i like the play it's like
you're bigging them
up you're also keeping it real yeah and
making it a little funny so it's like i
think if he would have just like posted
like all love people would be like ah
you caught him you wasn't keeping that
energy wet yeah
you know but that's interesting that
like now he has become a prisoner of his
character
yeah he can't even be genuine now
because they don't expect him to
and the human being version of that
would be hey
we had a bit of a falling out but you
can't deny this guy's greatness as a
broadcaster
rest in peace we had our differences but
you were great at what you did or
whatever yeah
this is clearly exactly what you said he
is trapped in his own character
he can't get out of it he has to stay in
character to mourn somebody
yeah but i'm okay with it just because i
know what type of dude larry king was
like larry king could be a douchebag
it's a valid point
so it's like yeah the same energy is
kept in life and death
i'm not that man if it's mother teresa
then it might be a little bit
um of a douche move
yeah you know what i mean if you're
taking care i don't even really know
much about mother teresa but she's in it
she's larry king
that's that's exactly what i'm talking
about we don't know about mother teresa
she says diana is another one that i'm
like yeah yeah i guess
princess diane also yeah we like you
because you're cute you're the aoc of
the royal family oh [ __ ]
that's fired i'm just saying i'm not
shot fired i'm just saying like if she
was bustardo
yeah would we care probably a little bit
we don't care about fergie
remember in there like a fergie one yeah
yeah yeah she's a red-headed something
about whales
yeah princess of wales or some [ __ ]
there's some redheaded royal
that we don't give a flying [ __ ] talk
about the lady lumps girl i'm like
so nobody cares and princess diana was a
piece so they cared about everything she
did
she ran a foot race and won some people
like oh my god this is the
most athletic royal ever you also like
save the kid who was drowning or some
[ __ ] like that's actually a real
water what's your name i've done that
but
i saved my boy what do you mean when i
was young he jumped in the water
michael this kid somebody threw him in
the water actually and he couldn't swim
so i saved his
ass big [ __ ] deal you supposed to do
that you wanna pat on the back
you wanna do something special save
yourself when you're drowning yeah
that's hard to do
that [ __ ] is lit best waves of all time
best waves in the past two or three
years almost died
no but no seriousness i don't know it's
one of these things where we just gotta
love someone because we're supposed to
yeah we just take everybody's word for
it what did she do what did diana do she
i give her this she wanted to break away
from the royal family yeah she was like
i'm not gonna do this
[ __ ] yeah that's pretty cool yeah it's
an institution a big one
yeah you're gonna get a lot of [ __ ] for
that right that's what's crazy though
she tried to do it and they loved her
for it but then
what's his other chick harry harry and
megan they do it and everyone everyone
hates her for it because she's black and
he's a simp
yeah that's true yeah it's a shame bro
yeah royal simp
yeah he closes all the cabinets bro i
mean yeah but they out here getting
money
they are getting money so maybe they
have money like you have their own
family but it's not a good point it's
either live on an allowance
that's a great point it's either live on
an allowance and have to do all their
rules or let's go ahead and get our own
money and we could be free i mean what
are the rules out like
this once a year she's not allowed to
like
speak out like there's they have there's
like a nail color you're not allowed to
have
now that that's a big deal but they get
that exact with rules maybe that rule in
and of itself who gives a [ __ ]
but there's so many rules they get all
the way down to like you're not allowed
to have this nail
color this nail type or some [ __ ] you
have to represent the family and go to
like all these
banquets of people care about and [ __ ]
like that like they have
roles and [ __ ] that they got to do
they're like yo [ __ ] that let's just get
out here we can live free say whatever
the [ __ ] we want and make our own money
but also i respect that yeah low-key i
respect that
[ __ ] the rules man yeah there's nothing
that is more valuable than freedom
facts no that is
what are they say what the royal
whatever they happen
but since they're stepping out is
someone else coming in no no they don't
recruit
oh they they just like they just like
lose their place in line
yeah yeah he was dumb low in life wasn't
gonna
so there's no chance for him to be king
really unless his brother got murked
yeah okay yeah so i think that i like
the move
the freedom bro there's no [ __ ] price
on that whatsoever i think
if he was the oldest they ain't leaving
because as soon as
grandma got to die at some point and
then dad gonna die and then we're king
of [ __ ] england
yeah but this kid is gonna be prince
she's holding on foot
like she's holding him she's not going
man i don't think so she's not going to
be one of them lizard people
but what yeah would you want to be king
in england
you know there's no responsibility
you're just arcading why not that's what
it was
i don't know like i'm just i don't know
i don't think so like i would rather the
responsibility
give me the responsibility if i got to
do all this other [ __ ] [ __ ] like not
wear
a certain colored jacket and put a
[ __ ] bonnet in my wife's head every
time we go to this event and you wear
those stupid hats and [ __ ] like
if i gotta do all this nonsense i want
some responsibility i bet there's a lot
not a show pony i bet there's a lot more
rules for the women than men i bet dudes
be doing like i'm the king what you
really finna tell me
i think they could tell you a lot if
there's all these rules yeah i'm king
so well i can't get up a little bit
that's have you seen them king it up
there's no king yet it's the queen's is
she gonna follow all the rules you know
i mean but the king you give a [ __ ]
i'm just saying you're telling me
nothing bro no i need responsibility bro
don't give me all these rules without
responsible would you rather be like
king of england or like
king of saudi arabia or some [ __ ]
president of the united states of
america 2032.
oh king of saudi arabia yeah yeah that's
lit
100 you do whatever the [ __ ] whatever
you want bro yeah
let's go a journalist write some [ __ ]
[ __ ] about you
bye bye bye bye
bye yeah yeah think about that [ __ ]
couple journalists would be gone that we
know
gone gone i'm just saying dude that
is a little bit more enticing to me yeah
than being king of england like what's
the uh
what are you doing you're not even doing
like i imagine like the royal family in
england back in the day was very
valuable and helpful to the people
you know they probably were part of like
uh you know movements to
maybe liberate and empower them in some
ways you know i know they try to stay
apolitical but
sometimes like the royal family i think
like during the franco era in spain
was was crucial in like getting spain
out of this
sort of like tyrannical like fascist
regime i'm pretty sure and um so they're
like beloved
in that way but now you can't even do
that [ __ ] man [ __ ] that
yeah it seems not worth it yeah why
would you
i think king is great can you do
whatever [ __ ] you want to you're not
telling me nothing oh there's rules from
other kings all right well i'm the new
king
let's assume you do have to play by
those rules then it might be a little
restrictive bro what could it make it's
easier for him because he's religious
ah so you already played by rules
interesting perhaps what does the king
do
what does the king england do that a
rich person in america couldn't do
yeah nothing right yeah yeah you can't
speak out
son you're not even the richest yes you
can't speak out
bro that you're not even the richest
person in your country
jk rowling got more money than you yeah
it's just embarrassing bro
think about that but i mean the heads
aren't always the richest the president
isn't the richest yeah but if you really
can't but we're talking about the king
about president like if you're king
forever you got to go
have it bro you got to have it ready to
go at any point in time
you can't have this little writer chick
you know [ __ ] on you stunting with
those fire ass buying your house
she might just buy your house yeah no no
no no no she could film a movie in there
easy though
easy yeah i'm just saying like it just
seems to me
it's like it's like a shitty job
it's a shitty job being king of england
would anybody really want i don't blame
this chick for breaking away from the
family
makes perfect sense i don't blame diana
i don't blame none of them
what a [ __ ] idiot and i see why they
want to what makes
perfect sense why would anybody still
want to do it they don't need a king
england doesn't need a king nobody in
that family needs to do it
and if anyone saw the princess diaries
you could see how strict it is
exactly it's like getting chosen
boyfriend probably watching that [ __ ]
right now
wow yo it's jokes it's jokes i love your
boyfriend
you know it's jokes yeah but we were
you